okay y'all i have been having audio
issues lately and it seems like
i'll test it on my own before the stream
and i'll be wrong i will think that it's
working and it's not
so i'm gonna be testing this hold on
hold on
okay y'all i have been having audio
issues lately and it seems like
okay now let me try it again what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel
i'll test it on my own
that it's working and it's not
okay
[Music]
eva come back i need you
please one more time i promise we'll be
done i promise it's the last one i think
i got it
guys when i'm yelling is that okay
um the camera it's gonna be better
that's a different day the lighting's
off right now
i'm just trying to get this eva i need
you
just go sit there for one second i just
want to hear if like it picks up both of
us at the same time
i think i fixed it
um
you realize it's live
this is my sister eva um okay talk she
won't be she's kind of tired she won't
be on the stream tonight
um okay eva talk to me
you just pranked me i didn't prank you i
was testing it out because sometimes it
sounds weird when i go live
um
how do you feel about being a hippie now
not a hippie she's a hippie
not a hippie oh the crystal in my bra
keeps getting out she is she's right
guys
she's everything we warn you guys about
i'm just kidding
she believes in like
you know hippie stuff guys how does this
sound let me know in the chat
let me know in the chat how does this
sound
y'all
it's a struggle bus i'm sorry
can you hear her can you hear eva okay
and go sit down and try this mic too
i only need two
oh wait actually
let me
turn off
her mic sounds good too because her gain
is up and mine's
mine's 2.5
tell me if she sounds better when i go
like this
okay wait so i'm turning down her gain
and my gain at the same time so they're
at the same levels hold up
um
no audio troubles okay
okay guys i'm going to try my intro
because it's louder and i just want to
see if it's going to have issues so
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i got a
special guest on the channel my little
sister eva who doesn't want to be here
[Music]
okay let me listen to my phone
i promise we'll be done i promise
the camera it's going to be better
that's a different day i want to hear if
like it picks up both
[Music]
talk a little bit
i don't know
okay let me let me ask you a question
am i your favorite sister no okay well
your second favorite says third
four
there's only four to choose
from what's that
it's not looking too good for your hair
what the
okay okay okay hear me out hear me out
who's ahead of me and why
um mary doesn't bug me
what the i'm in europe
you lived at the house for like a year
barely i had a boyfriend i was barely
there
yeah but then once you guys like
then you're like all sad and like crying
and you're like you've been taking my
phone
oh and i cried i was sad we broke up
too many emotions
what the i'm sorry i'm human
oh my goodness it makes you feel any
better gabrielle is under you under me
yeah
like she's ahead of me or behind me
now i'm confused because i thought i was
last are you saying i'm not last i'm
saying you both last oh okay why is she
last
you met her
what you met her
okay i'm just looking you said it was
because i have too many emotions yes it
was gabrielle um
okay what about
what about brothers who's your favorite
brother greg
what's that
because you don't see him exactly what
the
okay who's your favorite brother you see
charles
because he doesn't talk much chess talks
not as much as austin and adam
again he's not annoying he gave me a
lego dinosaur too
try it go sit there try the third mic
guys so you you can hear everything okay
okay put that there
um
okay
okay guys let us know how this sounds
also this isn't going to be that
this is i'm going to fix that that's a
later problem
what
okay
stop pretending to be that's a troll
stop pretending to be my friend i'm
gonna send her a video of this
because
i told her the other day i thought it
was actually her
okay
gabby look at this troll
pretending to be you
look at this nonsense
it's like sir you're getting blocked
blocked
what are you
that's not cheap fix it
fix what okay so can you guys hear him
not liking the camera though okay well i
have to turn on the lights
ah
first of all
i think i gotta change a setting on the
camera because i think it's on a weird
setting right now
okay and then
let's go to this one
why is there a little margarita glass in
the corner oh so if people send
donations they're like they get it's
exciting
like the the tip jar fills up
can you see everything
yeah like if i was sitting down would
you see it
i think it needs to be taller yeah
there are
it's sort of blurry it's not blurry
anymore is it
this is like
a daily struggle i'm telling you
y'all don't even know
okay
[Music]
to bring um
higher possibly but like further back
that's better isn't it yeah
okay
my pants look at my pants guys
look at she turned into a hippie i
couldn't believe it
um that's
what are you
i'm just wearing comfy clothes
the rest of my clothes are just
sweatpants and t-shirts
sounds like hippie behavior you know
maybe i'm not gonna give you your mic
stuff that i brought
you brought me it's like ten dollars
like i was excited but it's not like
i travel all this way just to get
berated by you
berated
being attacked
is a hippie a bad thing i thought we
include everybody
i'm not a hippie though okay i won't
call you a hippie anymore
what should i call you
that's like if i called you a gangster
i am a gangster
[Music]
like i think
i think that would be a very accurate
depiction actually i think i'd be a
great drug dealer
i think i'd be like really good at it
actually
lighting is good need to fix framing
it's okay now i'm gonna do this before
every show so you guys can
actually if i sit here
i feel like you need to move the frame
over towards you a little bit
better
guys i fixed some of the panels too
not very well
do you see how uneven it is like you can
even like line them up correctly
are you gonna fix it for me
no i'm lazy i already wipe down your
counter and your stove i cooked dinner
it looks like you tried to wipe it down
and failed
okay we can't
you gotta tell them that i tell them i'm
wifey
i'm like such a good cooker and cleaner
i'm like so wifey
why do you don't tell them don't tell
them
okay wait should i put it back further
you think
i think it needs to be a little further
back
i like so much weight
[Music]
oh yeah so much wipe material
yeah like crazy
you're so much wife material that i
would never marry you what the
you're you're you like men
yeah what's your point
and we're related okay but if i were a
man i wasn't related to you i would not
call you away from me what the
mom said i am
mom said you're waiting material she
totally did it
okay well even if that actually did
happen how often does mom tell the truth
shut up shut up
is this centered
on the screen yeah
because it's still cutting my forehead
off
um
anna your dog is licking the table i
don't know why she keeps licking that
spot
like there's nothing there
maybe she needs more iron
but it's always that spot
yeah okay
okay so she says speak into the mic so
that means into the mic that means hold
up let me flip this
she's still licking the table okay hold
ellie
okay wait
oh you know what i bet it's because
yours isn't up
at the same level
okay talk again
talk again
echo is that too loud guys
they said most men want to wife up a
beefy gal like pearl beefy that's gabby
roberts again beefy
i would have preferred thick thank you
okay guys does that sound better can you
hear wait you gotta talk
what i gotta talk
ellie go back to licking the table
okay what did you miss the most when i
left for england your dog
okay second most
um
no i think you talk about copper's
no
the mic is perfect it was nice having
somebody else to pick up amelia
okay but what about you see that she's
loving opportunistically right here
i know you know mgtow ellie
are you licking the table
hannah's dog licks a table
anyone have any idea why she licks a
table yeah
why on earth anyone have any idea why
she's licking a table okay
um okay guys how do we sound do we sound
good
no
stop saying no
your sister is so mean i hope she's
trolling you see this they see the
bullying
ellie
oh my god
you know i'm gonna lock her in the room
with you when i start the show
i'm gonna put on your bed
why is your bed so low to the ground
i think it's a european thing
just came with the apartment this table
came with the apartment
oh this is better i think
in terms of height because before i felt
like it was too low
yell really quick how does that sound
with a high pitch what up guys welcome
to the just pearly things youtube
channel today i got my little sister on
the channel what up davis gang
every time i hear you do that it just
gets cringier okay what the i have a
great intro
okay wait let's see what gabby says
yeah see
not
gabby is not in the chat
it's good sounds
good i think we got it guys
like asm makeup a little
this is poor youtubing yes
what do you mean
i don't get an audio guy
i have you guys
i don't i'm i'm doing all this [ __ ] by
myself
i'd be struggling some days okay
how tall are you five eight
also how old are you say it loud and
clear for the chat
loud and clear because i know how you
guys beat
18 no you're not
no she's not
say how old you are to the chat i can
answer this question in a week and it'll
be correct no no say it loud and clear
to the chat
remember when we left you at a gas
station
don't tell them that
don't tell them that
and it took women down like 15 minutes
to figure out you are gone okay number
one
they missed me
they
missed me okay
look at me look at me
they missed me did they though they did
it's like wild
how much they missed me like don't
it wasn't like i had to call them and
tell them to please come back at all
that would have been really sad
remember we left gabriella in a jerk
no i don't think i was there you left
sorry bella if you're watching this we
were like in starbucks we're like wait
gabrielle
yeah she was young then too i don't know
how old she was but i was 18 so she had
to have been younger than that
you're so old now
i know
that was six years ago i was 12. i don't
like being this old i wish i was 18
again
but then again i was pretty dumb at 18.
so tikka river was like 14.
i'm not that young
to you
i mean he's young but she could have
figured it out like i i flew to germany
alone when i was 12.
i feel i flew to japan alone when i was
in eighth grade yeah we've lived
different lives though
yeah gabrielle's not the most
independent
it was it was funny um i don't know i
don't really
watch like i don't know but
it was funny when
um
guys when i invited her to come see me i
was like what do you want to see anybody
was like i've seen everything in england
we've lived different lives
i'm not the tourist type
five eight and she's still the runt the
litter
that's true you are the shortest in the
family right
yeah did amelia outgrow you
no i know but it's funny because you're
tall
[Music]
that's true like you're tall
i think amelia's like five nine
she done growing everyone says she's
gonna outgrow me um everyone said
gabrielle would outgrow me too
not quite
yeah i don't know how much longer amelia
has because i stopped growing after
freshman year and yeah me too it was
almost over and i was a year young in
school so i really would have stopped
growing in like eighth grade if i was in
the correct grade
yeah
your dog is still licking the table
like what do you think about the
patriarchy
all right they want to know in the chat
ellie
ellie stop
i think this would look better if it was
slanted down
my pants look at them guys
see she got hippie pants which is like
nuts
don't hate on my hippie pants oh now i'm
too tall
okay
do you think the patriarchy is real
i don't know hannah
that's a yes can we just
okay wait where are you going to college
funny funny funny
it's a funny question
she is a horse my eva's the animal lover
of the family she has like chickens and
horses i had chickens when i was younger
but i killed them all
on accident like not intentionally ellie
[Music]
ellie
like why does she keep licking that spot
get her assault that's what i do with my
horse because he used to do the same
thing oh really yeah
i don't know if you can get salt looks
for dogs but
i have one for a horse
salt lick
let me see
boom
for horses and
i'm sure you can get something for a dog
can i just get the one for the horse and
give it to the dog i don't know if you
can give dog salt licks
i don't know why not
i don't know why not either but i just
feel like there's something wrong with
it
oh yeah my first name's hannah guys
everyone calls me by my middle name
outside of my family
it's kind of weird when that switched
wasn't it
yeah i was very confused who they were
talking about
yeah i started at like volleyball in
college
yeah
and it stopped messing with it you're
never going to get how you want it
i need to get like a
a guy here
did i get a new 4k camera i did not
i did not this is the same camera i've
had the whole time
but if you'd like to donate
feel free
okay
well i think that's it for now this is
kind of fun right you want to come on
later
no
okay she'll be on tomorrow we're gonna
do a sister show before the show
she's really excited and really
supportive
somebody call the cops oh my god was it
annoying to you when
like i first got on the internet i feel
like i'd be so annoyed if my older
sister was on the internet
no
did you expect that out of me
no but yes what do i like and dislike
about eva
um okay guys that's the end of the night
good night no no i'm gonna tell you i
think eva's very funny and creative
and she's also really smart and has like
common sense that's what i like about
her
what do i not like
she's kind of rude a little bit
but i'm kind of rude it kind of runs in
the family
what do you like and dislike about me
nothing springs to mind nothing oh my
god okay
okay we're